treat yourself it's the best day of the
year the best day of the year I hate
disappointing just one person
and I really hate disappointing
Burlington Coat Factory
if you go in there with 645 dollars
you are literally a king
what did we learn this week well one
thanks for me
my team is much much faster at coming to
decisions than I thought they would be
number two never buy a fur coat with a
credit card until you absolutely have
the money to pay for it
and three you should know that some
people think it's cool to throw buckets
of fake blood on you as you are walking
out of Burlington Coat Factory
in the building he had announced that
Tom having fun is in the building
[Music]
Donatella T-Mobile three words for you
treat yo self treat yourself to 2011.
once a year Donna and I spend a day
treating ourselves what do we treat
ourselves to clothes treat yourself
fragrances treat yourself massage it
treat yourself mimosas treat yourself
fine leather goods treat yourself it's
the best day of the year the best day of
the year this is is a lot of credit card
debt yeah tell me about it you know Jan
has my credit cards and she's
using them as if I'm made of money she
thinks I'm a human ATM machine
okay 125 Amazon
oh Best of The Muppet Show on DVD
classic
twelve hundred dollars what's a core
Blaster extreme that is by far the best
way to strengthen your core this machine
you sit on a stabilizer ball you put
your feet into the power stirrups you
reach up and you grab onto the super rod
and you twist and you twist and you
twist it strengthens your entire core
your back core your arm core
your the Marine Corps actually uses it I
think that's how they got core
I left a little present for Angela
I think she's going to like it because I
found it outside Advanced Refrigeration
all alone and I told her in the note
that the cat came to find her
that they were destined to be together
I got game
okay the green bar is what you spend
every month on stuff you need like a car
and a house
that's so cool I have my name at the top
it's a red bar is what you spend on
non-essentials like magazines
entertainment right things like that
this scary black bar
is what you spend on things that no one
ever ever needs like multiple magic sets
professional bass fishing equipment I
could do this so fast is this PowerPoint
welcome to Nirvana the plaza at Eagleton
there's a reflecting pull out back
there's an old-timey train that runs
through the mall and three burberries if
you tell your friend hey meet me at
burberry's they gotta specify which one
let's hit it
I really want to stress and I like this
Crystal Beetle but it's expensive and
there's no use for it down amigo
treat yourself
velvet slippies cashmere socks velvet
pants cashmere Turtle I'm a cashmere
velvet candy cane treat yourself
this is insane the ceilings are lower
than they were last week that I don't I
don't know if you showed me this same
unit or not and Michael this is the unit
where are all the hot people I was told
that there would be all these attractive
singles and as far as I can tell I'm the
best looking person here there's a basic
principle in real estate that you should
never be the best looking person in the
development
it's sort of common sense because if you
are
then
you had no place to go but down
is this a financial thing if it's a
financial thing what some people do is
they rent out the third bedroom
I am not going to rent the third bedroom
I want a price reduction or I am a walk
you will lose seven thousand dollars if
you walk away right
I made a right decision
I'm glad I find it I'm a homeowner fun
good to be a homeowner diversifying
those are good
this is fun we're having fun totally
having fun can you imagine those poor
saps stuck at the office today
why if you can follow big money on one
thing not sock money what would it be
oh my God oh my God oh my God this is a
whole new level of nerd you're right
this is ridiculous what am I doing wait
no no no no no I mean that in a good way
Ben listen to me you're part of the
treat yourself team now okay if that
costume somehow makes you happy you're
gonna buy it you're gonna wear it out of
the store okay you're gonna treat
yourself yeah you know what I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna
I'm gonna treat myself thanks you guys
thank you
I really needed this
is myself
uh oh Batman's crying
whoa video iPod oh wow geez somebody
really got carried away with this Spirit
of Christmas
it was me I got carried away with the
spirit it wasn't there a 20 limit on the
gift
this is 400 bucks
and you don't know that yeah you left
the price tag off I did yeah why oh
shoot wow okay well who cares doesn't
matter what I spent what matters is that
Christmas is fun right
Michael oh hey for me
what is in here
and it comes to 166.41 all right now
you're the expert is this enough to get
20 people plastered
15 bottles of vodka
yeah I should do it we'll box it up
there's actually one more cake you
haven't tried yet Donna has chosen me to
be the butler of honor at her wedding
now granted Butler of honor is a term I
made up but it's not a job I take
lightly that's why I'm about to give her
a surprise bigger than when LeBron went
back to Miami
oh my God DJ blunts what is happening
right now I think you know what's
happening but but for real though what
what's happening
oh it's for real okay and it's the
biggest one yet I still don't know
what's happening so what's happening not
an answer to my question oh my God read
the cake still unclear tell you what
what's happening treat yourself it's the
best day of the year
[Music]
treat yourself in Beverly Hills
[Music]
right here please ladies and gentlemen
off to our right you can see the house
that belongs to Bruce Willis and
Christina Aguilera and to our left is
Usher's Los Angeles residence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so for the basic elbow bedazzling it's
140 custom art starts at 250. I would
like three big ass diamonds surrounded
by their own set of tiny ass diamonds
that would fall into our Supreme
collection 600. Thomas what do you
suggest uh
uh treat yourself
Church the gentleman is right I'm gonna
go ahead and treat myself lazy for
fingernails I came up with that you want
it it's 275.
yeah lays my nails off please
but don't be obvious can I get uh the me
soft shell crap Josh Groban he's eating
his own Sushi that's the most baller
thing I've ever seen